[Music]
another way
in September of 2022 a video began
circulating online of a man named
yevgeni pregorzan
at the prison in Russia speaking to
inmates
and offering them the chance to fight in
Ukraine
precaution was an acquaintance of
Vladimir Putin's from Petersburg in the
1990s
close to Vladimir Putin
start focusing more on catering
businesses and rest
earning himself the nickname Putin's
Chef in the beginning he stayed in the
shadows he rarely appeared
he was named by some Western officials
as being in charge of Wagner group but
the Kremlin kept it very hush-hush they
didn't want it to be known that this
group really existed they denied knowing
anything about it
Wagner is nothing like what Americans
might understand as a private military
company Wagner are mercenaries For Hire
they Massacre and rape civilians they
exploit loot natural resources and they
carry it off much of this back to the
Kremlin
the significance of this video is it
immediately ties precaution to the
Wagner group he's always denied any
involvement but here you have him on
camera describing Wagner as his group
and describing what they're doing it was
a way of planting the flag and saying
I'm in charge here I've got permission
to do what whatever I'd like
[Music]
in fact the function of the coming out
story to convince us that that is the
only story that there is to know
this is a business story at the end of
the day this is a story about the
exchange of billions and billions of
dollars for large-scale weapon platforms
for train and equip missions for oil and
gas exploitation
what we're really seeing here is a very
strange organization that doesn't look
at all like your classic private
military company in fact it's probably
better to call it a state-backed
paramilitary cartel
foreign
shadowy pro-russian forces here
violently took over government
facilities
[Music]
the tentacles of Wagner spread across
Africa Syria and Ukraine
they Relish in their brutality
nothing could be more appropriate than
designating it as a foreign terrorist
organization
Ferguson ever actually threatened
Vladimir Putin's hold on power
it's absolutely unclear how this will
end
[Music]
up
my name is
Wagner Fighters
um
in the 10 years since its founding the
Wagner group has evolved from a small
guns for higher operation
into a sprawling network of businesses
that has been active on four continents
setting up a broader network of
infrastructure where Wagner could
protect a surge presence
response to a given opportunity or
threat and also it creates the
opportunity to sort of Lily Pad their
influence from one country to another
Wagner currently has approximately 50
000 Personnel deployed to Ukraine
including 10 000 contractors and forty
thousand convicts
President Putin wants Russia to be a
great power again he wants it to have
control throughout not only Europe and
Asia but also in Africa and other parts
of the world he's been able to send in
his mercenaries through Wagner to do the
Dirty Work
The Wall Street Journal examined
shipping records government databases
sanctions documents and corporate
records to identify 64 companies linked
to Wagner's founder if Gainey burgosian
we found more than half of those are
being used by Wagner as a complex
network of front companies to hide the
flow of money and materials that
ultimately connect to the Kremlin
neither the Kremlin nor pagosian
responded to requests for comment about
our findings
the monies would flow back through the
corporate form and they could be used to
pay salaries they could be used to pay
Weaponry they could be used to pay for
everything that a military needs but not
coming through the Russian state
it's always going to be a game of
whack-a-mole for the U.S and other
governments because the more companies
that are sanctioned the more companies
will be created to evade sanctions
foreign
group does is directed by the state for
the state to the profit of the state
but from the beginning
the Wagner group was carefully
engineered to hide its connection to the
Kremlin
Ukrainian and Western officials say that
the way it was done was give any
precaution through his catering company
Concord was making money from defense
industry contracts so he was getting
contracts to provide food and other
services for the Russian army which he
was then able to reinvest into the
Wagner group it is a classic money
laundering technique Concord catering
was what it sounds like it was set up as
a catering company that had sweetheart
deals with the Kremlin so the Kremlin
would pay it and it was the catering
company and then as part of that there
are ways to skim that money off the top
and ensure that the money goes to the
appropriate folks that pregosian wants
to pay it was through parts of that
money flow that it's expected that
Wagner got its start
origin story of the Wagner group is
basically a battlefield rumor
at the beginning of the war in donbass
and the annexation of Crimea in 2014 we
saw a lot of guys without Insignia you
know the little green men running around
and they were often talked about as not
being there
the Kremlin has always believed that
Ukraine should be part of Russia and
that naturally the ukrainians should
support Russia so it tried to ferment a
revolution some kind of Uprising in
eastern Ukraine Russia used small
mercenary groups to support pro-russian
separatists in their fight against
Ukrainian forces now all of these groups
was Wagner because they offered
plausible deniability for for the
Russians they could say that these were
locals that had simply decided to rise
up against the rulers in Kiev
there are no Russian units in the east
of Ukraine no special services no
instructors those are all local
residents
I just graduated University
I've visited this territory at the
middle of summer 2014.
[Music]
I participated as activism to provide
humanitarian aids to this region
I witnessed a lot of evidence when
people could not explain some kind of
military crimes and attacks against the
local population
they had a lot of misunderstanding who
was responsible for these attacks
as the war in donbos developed a former
Russian Special Forces officer began to
make a name for himself Dimitri utkin
was one of the original commanders in
Wagner
and in fact his call sign was Wagner and
that's what gave the unit its name now
he was known as Wagner because of his
Neo-Nazi sympathies
Russia's attempt to foment an uprising
in donbass ultimately faced stiff
resistance from the Ukrainian Army
and according to the Ukrainian
intelligence service the Kremlin used
utkin and his Wagner unit to Target
pro-russian separatists who oppose
negotiating a ceasefire with Ukraine
there were a lot of local activists who
became leader of local militia this days
but it was not goals of Russians they
were not interested in having any kind
of real leaders all these people would
possibly become uncontrollable for
Putin's regime
the majority of local leaders of local
militia of local people were killed step
by step under some strange circumstances
essentially they were a death squad that
was sent out to clean up any of the
political problems that the Kremlin was
dealing with during this negotiation
process the might or for Wagner group or
Rose from year to year because they
appear to be very effective for this
Russian authoritarian regime
Putin himself he could hide any kind of
his criminal activities using this this
kind of troops
[Music]
depression
is
[Music]
in 2015 Russia intervened in the Syrian
Civil War and Wagner was used to protect
energy resources for the Assad regime
it was the beginning of a new business
model for the group
and in return
they get a share of the natural
resources the Looting of the country it
was a pivotal role in a conflict that
put one of Russia's most important
allies at risk
is
that meant Wagner and the Russian
military fought against any combination
of u.s-backed rebels Kurdish forces and
Isis
Wagner employed its fighters in Syria
through a company called evropolis
everopolis was also the company the
Syrian government hired to protect its
oil fields
[Music]
um
ultimately these shell companies that
are paying the salaries of wider group
Fighters they're nothing more than that
they're just paper pass-throughs that
allow Russia to manage money and men and
make sure that there are no prying eyes
in the deals
oil was particularly lucrative for
Wagner in Syria
everopolis's contract with the Syrian
government shows that for every oil
field it captured it got 25 percent of
production
25 of the natural resources the energy
resources that were able to be exploited
an incredible amount for a company far
field in Russia by 2017 Wagner captured
at least four of the country's largest
oil and gas fields which earned the
group tens of millions of dollars per
year from each field make sure that you
secure the oil and gas get it before the
Americans get it or get it before the
Kurds get it but get there that was the
objective
al-shire gasfield and homs is one of the
largest in Syria
in 2017 Wagner worked with the Syrian
military to defend it from Isis
many of the Syrian troops had been
forced into service by the Assad regime
during a battle with Isis some of those
Syrian Fighters tried to escape
Bogner found one of them and decided to
make an example of him
his name
was Muhammad Ismail
[Music]
um
Wagner Fighters filmed themselves as
they tortured killed and mutilated
Muhammad Ismail we see kind of this
impulse toward memorializing terrorizing
incidents this helps with the kind of
psychological effects don't mess with us
we're coming and when we come be
prepared
in 2018 Wagner forces attempted to
capture the Conoco gas plant in kosham
from U.S backed Rebel forces
foreign
[Music]
and then when the Russian regular forces
couldn't give the Americans an answer a
satisfactory answer as to who was down
there doing that fighting creeping
toward the Conoco Gas Plant well it was
kind of all bets off
the U.S military sent up a whole bunch
of air cover and it was an absolute
bombardment
is
innovagner lost the fight for the Conoco
Gas Plant they still served a very
important purpose
taking heavy losses that the Russian
military couldn't you can't count what
you can't see and you can't count what
you don't know
one of my duties was to actually fly on
board of Transport aircrafts Russian
military aircrafts were filled with
bodies of killed in action operators
from Wagner group what I witnessed being
at Mission as Syria as an Air Force
officer was this Wagner group used all
the resources of Russian official
military
they used their military Aviation they
use their logistic capabilities they use
their military bases
by 2019 the Syrian government awarded
several Wagner Companies oil and gas
drilling rights to about 10 000 square
miles of land across the country
as recently as 2021 a Wagner company was
awarded oil and gas drilling rights for
2 000 square miles of offshore territory
some would point to Syria as a pretty
successful model of how business could
be done they went in you know
surreptitiously they managed to grab
back a lot of the important oil gas and
mineral resources for the Syrian State
and for Russia
and they did that you know at minimal
cost
Russia's found itself a very successful
model and it wanted to replicate it
and the group did just that
as it expanded to Africa
I'd say the biggest success for the
Wagner group that we know of now is in
the Central African Republic
[Music]
um
in Africa Wagner set up even more shell
companies to mine natural resources and
sell them around the world
Wagner was able to do that through
offering Security Services
Wagner targets countries with ongoing
security issues some are former French
colonies with governments weakened in
the wake of reduced French military
presence
in the Central African Republic Wagner
uses a company called siwa Security
Services to provide security to the
president and other high-level officials
siwa is a subsidiary of low buy invest
which has at least three mining licenses
in the country
[Music]
um
January of 2018 where they quickly got
to work carrying out training tasks and
setting up bases where they could help
to instruct local Armed Forces
foreign
[Music]
ER quickly got to work taking over mines
one of the largest is a roughly 138
square mile swath of land known as the
nadasama mine
it was a small scale mine where
everything was done by hand
Wagner developed it into the only
industrialized gold mine in the country
I'm a lawyer for axman a company
business Central African Republic with
listed in Toronto exchange actually was
granted the nasima mining license back
in 2010.
unfortunately in 2013 a civil war broke
up so obviously as a company we weren't
able to go into exploration
Rebel groups like The Union for peace
known as UPC took control of the
nadasama mine for the next several years
until Wagner forces took over around
2017.
um
[Music]
chef
WPC
code cash
is
2019 we received a document from the
government saying that our permit was
canceled
two months later we illustrate the
information that in fact
Midas which in fact was run by Wagner
who was awarded our license in the
cinema
Midas resources is a Wagner company
created for mining in the Central
African Republic
the journal was unable to find any prior
mining history for Midas
in a 2011 report axeman projected
nadasama could produce more than 1.4
million ounces of gold over about eight
years
that's nearly 3 billion dollars worth at
today's prices
today the government has no way of
knowing what's going on in the field
because it has become off limit for the
government since uh Wagner took over
satellite imagery analyzed by The Wall
Street Journal further confirms Wagner's
Presence at the mine
this December 2022 image shows a me8 or
me 17 helicopter the same kind of
Choppers Wagner uses elsewhere in Africa
here a type of armored vehicle military
analysts call a Wagner wagon is
identifiable by its roof-mounted extra
tire and its pointed front end
these customized combat trucks were also
used by Wagner forces in Syria and Libya
satellite images show the expansion and
industrialization of the mine
on the right we can see heavy machinery
we're able to actually see some dump
trucks and diggers in the imagery that
have been expanding these open pit mines
on the left we can see the expansion of
facilities and two processing lines
together these developments show the
country's first industrialized gold mine
built by Wagner
do we not naive about the situation
it's highly unlikely that you will get
it back as Wagner linked companies took
control of Mines its Fighters killed
anyone in their path
one such incident occurred in 2021 in
the village of boyo about 100 miles
south of the nadasama mine
Elizabeth
the Muslim Community there was targeted
because Wagner forces and their allies
believe them to be helping the UPC
Rebels who previously controlled the
mine
oh
uh
[Music]
the boyo Massacre was documented in a
2022 report to the UN Human Rights
Council which detailed the brutal
assault on civilians there
[Music]
the boyo Massacre is one small example
of atrocities Wagner has committed
across the continent
at the same time wagner-backed companies
continue to spring up across Africa in
different sectors of the economy
particularly in the Central African
Republic
an overall Playbook is step one
enter into a military technical
agreement with country X Central African
Republic Mali you get the helicopters
you get the guys who fly the helicopters
get the jet fighters get the guys who
fly those jet fighters you get the
Infantry fighting Vehicles get the guys
to drive them that's the Playbook but
then there's a second layer we see this
Narrative of Russia coming in as a
friend and a helper repeated in various
types of propaganda and disinformation
ranging from Soviet art style Billboards
in cities in the Central African
Republic and even getting down to the
level of creating children's cartoons
[Music]
foreign
we will make sure that the story that
you're trying to sell to your electorate
is is the one that's sold on social
media
officials some people are just saddened
by what's happening in the country
things start getting worse and worse the
country has become a sort of rock state
with uh with the Wagner calling all the
shots on behalf of the government
McNair city disaster because
[Music]
foreign
us and European security officials told
the journal that Wagner is also trying
to expand to Burkina Faso Chad and Ivory
Coast
every weapon that goes into Africa
is money
every bit of gold that comes out of
Africa is money that money
Services a lot of different needs it has
been all along a sanctions management
strategy
insulating Russia from what would
inevitably come if it ever crossed the
line into Ukraine
after backing Wagner through its massive
expansion in Africa Russia called the
group back for the urgent need of the
state
a full-scale war on Ukraine
Wagner would soon outshine the Russian
military on the battlefield
it's expected that the money that Wagner
progosian and their front companies are
reaping throughout Africa hundreds of
millions of dollars a year
much of that is expected to go back to
Russia
some into pagosian's Pockets but much of
it for the war effort in Ukraine
the initial Invasion on February the
24th was carried out by the by the
Russian military liified missiles they
sent in warplanes and then they sent in
armored columns
and they very much thought that if this
was a war that would last for a few days
[Music]
we know that there was money flowing
outward from the Kremlin to pagosian and
his companies we know that some of that
money was funneled into Wagner
The Wall Street Journal reviewed
contracts between the Russian government
and 25 companies tied to pagosian likely
only a small portion of the total
collectively these companies won more
than 5 billion dollars in contracts
between 2014 and 2023.
with a notable spike in the amount in
the year after the War Began
so a significant amount of money for
guns for tanks for other Weaponry that
can be used that all needs to be funded
somehow
as moscow's plan to take key failed
Russian troops and Wagner Fighters were
stuck in towns on the outskirts of the
city
one example that we have of how the
Wagner group was active around kievas
from the village of motels according to
prosecutors and according to the
Ukrainian soldiers vagina group was
brought in as an interrogation and
torture team
October
foreign
[Music]
the board
as the lit venenkos ran from the
indiscriminate fire their daughter was
shot Nicola pleaded with the Russians to
save her
they were taken to a Russian base at a
nearby Farmhouse the
house
[Music]
is
foreign
it was a coupon
Sila
Suite is
the conflict evolved Russia's needs for
Wagner also evolved Russia put a lot
more focus on its operations in the east
of Ukraine
wagonal group became a critical part of
this
is
foreign
here you see them really serving the
purpose of doing a couple of different
things one that Frontline piece but also
they've obviously been very important
for Force mobilization
um
Wagner began recruiting from prisons to
make up for large Russian losses on the
battlefield and to avoid drafting more
civilians into the war
no one
yeah
[Music]
this method was used in World War II by
Stalin
going into the prisons pulling people
out putting them on the front line
turning them into cannon fodder
the move to recruit from prisons
signified a new phase for Wagner one in
which the group stepped firmly Out of
the Shadows it represents the clearest
evidence yet of just how connected
Wagner's operations are to the Kremlin
The Wall Street Journal interviewed
convicts recruited by Wagner and later
captured by Ukrainian forces who
described being transported from their
prisons to the front lines in Ukraine
with State resources
[Music]
social media videos gathered and
verified by the Journal showed dozens of
trucks with federal prison markings
arriving at commercial airports and
Military airfields across the country
at the airport in Panza Russia these
trucks can be seen driving onto the
tarmac
men who appear to be prisoners unload
from the trucks near several airplanes
at least one of which is registered to
the Russian Air Force
[Music]
Florida
foreign
[Music]
can recruit in prisons demonstrates uh
the level of power that he achieved
I think you can likely expect to see an
expansion for Wagner of its contracts
and ties within Russia so long as it's
perceived to be successful
is
by May of 2023 the man who started out
10 years ago as Putin's Chef was openly
attacking Russia's Ministry of defense
and its top commander in Ukraine
acts that would send most to prison
foreign
group to continually change according to
Russia's fortunes when it comes to Arms
guns gas oil and gold
I think it's likely that in the future
you won't have any contracts with the
Wagner group publicly in any
jurisdiction outside of Russia or its
close allies
may see a new name could be anything
could be Tchaikovsky group we don't know
at this point in time Wagner activity is
confirmed on at least four continents
it's not only about Africa
it's also about Latin America
[Music]
it's not just that Russia is spreading
its influence in these countries but
Russia is further destabilizing some of
the areas where Global Security is at
its weakest
democracy is at stake and many of these
countries
but what's at stake is even something
more fundamental for the people of those
jurisdictions it's their very lives
thank you
[Music]
foreign